the first thing we mentioned
is to understand that
there is what i'm calling an alchemical
aspect to your training
what i mean by that is
that you're training involves
almost in numerous aspects that come
together to make your practice
so there's going to be
not only
the positioning of my body
but also
my thoughts my feelings and you go
deeper
my sleep patterns my nutrition
my relationships my world view my
perspectives all of these things go into
what we call a practice it's not just
my
intellect okay
and there the reason they all go in is
because they are concentric to each
other so
the state of being that i'm in
is in all of those things and therefore
a transformation of my being
must involve all of those things okay
and they will interrelate in ways that
us moderns
do not accept because
we are secular materialists we're
scientistic
um and
our religion is that
all right you want a new way of being
you need a new way of being
which means you need a new way of
thinking okay
so just to
have this for your sake
certain senses
certain feelings certain moves certain
perceptions
manifest in certain parts of the body in
certain ways the ones we mentioned so
far
is
a
psycho emotional
concern
with the opinions of others
of ourselves
will manifest
with tension in the lower legs okay so
you always look like you're high on the
mat always by it looks hot there's a
tension that brings the foot bones
together like this and then a tension in
the calf muscles and an extension in the
knees the back of the knees go backwards
this is related to that
concern with the opinions others have
so as you're training
you want to
make sure
that those areas of your body have
released
to release that you're going to have to
release
that
psycho-emotional egocentric
aspect okay
so keep those foot bones wide we also
know in order to do the internal aspects
of the art
i need to be able to have energy go all
the way to the ground so that it can
rebound out and tension in the lower
legs and foot bones
do not allow that it just stops it you
start adopting bracing angles okay
all right
when i do the move
think of it as a knife fight and in a
knife fight i don't want my arms out i
don't want my arms out away from my body
it makes them vulnerable
so
arms are in
and arms are in towards the center
watch this kind of hollywood
stuff
where your sword is out you see what it
does to my left elbow
it also exposes this
okay it exposes this to being pinned and
now i can't get the sword out
i want to operate on the center line of
my body
and my elbows are in
elbows in
now start to identify
the correct moves by the tension all the
while we are today paying attention to
the lower legs okay
so
sword is going to come out
in a tension-free
manner
when you feel the tension start to
develop
that's where you go to the next room
okay so
this is this is all tension free you can
see it's very easy to come out
and somewhere about here i start to feel
tension
in the upper
left quadrant so i'll exaggerate that
move and you see what it starts to do to
my right right scapula mechanism that's
tension
before you get there
on the eve of getting there you come up
so
here i am
keep going tension
stay here and you come up you can come
up a little bit more bring the sword out
a little more if i keep going you'll see
i'll get that same
tension in the right scapula mechanism
so it goes
not here
not there
out
it's at this point that the left hand
is going to take over
so
the left hand is going to take the sword
off
and you'll see
if i keep going here
i'm going to get that same tension in
the left
scapula you'll feel it in your grip and
you can't get it out okay so on the eve
of getting there that's when you start
to turn the side
a monitor for tension
lower legs because that's part of our
training today foot bones
monitor for tension
the reason i'm letting the sword draw
is you can tell the sword is free
i don't i'm not pulling the right hand
to get the sword free
so i move the right hand to here and
then it turns and the sword is free
hence it drops freely
in contrast
i'm here sword is not dropping and i
have to pull it out with the right hand
that's going to bring the tension back
into the right spot
into the right skeptical mechanism so
very release very relaxed
as you're doing this pay attention that
the left hand
does not prematurely grab it has the
same concern with
tension
as the right hand does so some of you
are
almost putting yourself in nico with
this grab like this
so you're grabbing here
but this grip is not the grip you want
on the koi gucci
you want to be able
to
uh be on the lips of the side
right here not over here like this okay
so on the lips well there's no way you
can grab that
at the beginning because the soup is in
the way so you know what don't grab it
yet
just move the sword with your thumb
and my left hand keeps moving until it
gets itself in position
um
you can see
if you're holding this
angle there
you're getting a kind of nico but if you
start to bring it up
you get rid of that nico do you see that
so when do you think you bring it up
uh when the right hand is coming up got
it
so you don't want to hold it here it's
oh this is all tense there's so much
friction on the sword there's tension
over here
and guess what
my feet are tense okay because i know
i'm messing up
and i know what my teacher is thinking
of me right now okay
let it all go
so all relax relax relax it comes up
comes up
turn and let the sword
okay let's try that nikki skit thank you
go
okay if if you can't feel the tension
which is very common right because we
we're tense all the time
so our body acclimates to it i can't
feel
that oh i have this egocentric concern
of everyone's opinion of me you can't
feel it you just go on living life that
way
so you also don't feel your legs like
that all the time you don't feel it you
you might stumble and trip because
obviously that affects balance but you
don't really pay attention why you don't
certainly don't connect it to that mood
okay
so let me give you some markers here
and you can start by the reverse so
first of all we're doing it from
a natural stance
because
you oftentimes can cheat by moving your
hip off so you're you're in a coma end
you can kind of turn your
hip out
to give you
freedom
that you require because of the tension
that you're putting into your
your draw so for example
tension you see and if i pull the right
hip out and the sword came out so we're
leaving our hips neutral
to make sure that we're doing the
technique right okay
that's the drill it also allows us to
work on those lower legs okay
uh if i can't feel the tension you can
know on your body you can mark on your
body
where the sword does what okay
oh you just have to start at the end so
on this nuke
uh we're doing the first cut of shohato
so
uh that
sword has to be
uh below my shoulder
because coming up it's gonna be in my
deltoid
and it's going to be a 45 degree angle
forward because again i'm not going to
open up this whole thing and stick my
limb out any further than i have to in a
knife flight so it's going to be at a 45
degree angle
and my
fist is going to be
just slightly below my shoulder to not
activate the deltoid okay
so in order to get there if i lift
this
and get that tension there
this sword is to continue would be
really high or
you're going to have a wave in your cut
as you lower the sword back down you see
like this
uh and we don't want to do that so you
you want to end up here
flat wrist
and you have some spectrum
that
the
tip of my sword
is can be no further in than the inside
of my tsuba and no further down than the
bottom of my tsum okay
that is what you're trying to do
and if you
realize where you are
you're going to realize that
this cannot go higher than around lower
sternum solar plexus level
so i will demonstrate that the tension
shows up there i go here okay there
there's the tension
oh and i come up
okay and i keep going there's the
tension again and i'm up above the lower
sternum solar plexus level if i keep
that cut even
you're going to see i'm activating the
delta
so this is done
lower
the same thing if i didn't do the cut
the sword would have dropped to show
that it was free
to do the cut you want it completely
free
of the side completely free that's where
the cut comes
release the tension
right now don't put any oomph into it
this is not under our control yet it's
still
got a lot of ego and a lot of tension so
we're just monitoring for tension
okay let's try
okay so now we're gonna add some
some power but you have to monitor if
you're adding so much power that you go
to lock your legs up
not correct or you bring the tension
back into
not correct but try to tempt yourself
with the tension and the locking the leg
step okay so you're going to do
and we'll do the
show men and as you come to do the
showmen
watch your body mind doesn't start going
power power kill kill power power
because those lower legs are gonna tense
on you okay
so release
release
keep your foot bone spreading on the cut
okay try it
and now we'll go over the noto and the
same principles are going to apply let
me have you over here on this side
the same principles are going to apply
uh it's a knife fight so don't stick
things out okay
work on your center line
watch for tension
and we are concentrating on that lower
leg
foot tension
and the
psycho emotional concern with the
opinion of others okay
so i'm doing the drill very relaxed
i'm going to bring everything back to
where it started
again don't negote yourself
relax bring it back to where you started
bring it back to your center line
keep the koi gucci grip
this pant is what
is keeping the sword parallel
in particular this pinky
and this thumb
not this ledge
do you get it that ledge does not work
and you know it doesn't work which is
why you start grabbing at this thing
this is this allows the sword to move i
can move this sword and i can re-grip
the sword okay when i go like this
that's not gonna work
out bring it to your center
keep this going at a 45 degree angle
don't bring it to 90 because now your
arm is sticking out
okay
and you have a lot of hidden energy here
a lot of yield energy for a sword fight
so
boom goes out to the 45. now you're like
oh that's where it stops and the left
hand picks up so the left hand is going
to pick up going back
turns at the tip
back in and down
to release the
tension in the shoulder mechanisms so
i'm doing the drill
boom
and don't let don't start tensing up
here
relax
the down gets rid of the knee
okay
here
relax
little turn
down
okay let's try